well I was originally going to render a
split screen video but that didn't work
out because for some reason Sony Vegas
decided to know and I couldn't change
anything and it would just keep on
crushing and showing weird black screens
and other things and apparently Sony
Vegas doesn't like split screen fraps
files which I can understand because
they're completely uncompressed and they
pretty much take in 10,000 gigs for only
five seconds so I can kind of see that
so I'm gonna edit it in later on but
basically what I'm doing right now is
something that I normally don't show
because I feel like it's kind of stupid
and well I don't really feel like it's
something that I really need to show I
mean it's all about the building things
and not removing things which is what
I'm currently doing and I'll explain for
a bit why I decided to remove this
building I just felt like it didn't
really feel and I didn't really fit in
the skyline that well it did add some
density to it but it just didn't really
fit with the looks of the other
buildings and even removed some of the
views of the other buildings and same
goes for this building and that's why
I'm removing this baby as well now I
recorded a split screen or at least I
recorded two separate video files of
Miriam quoting that first building from
two angles because I crashed the first
time so I had to redo it I was pretty
much forced to do it and I thought yeah
I might as well give it a try and see if
I can actually do a split screen video
but then it turned out that Sony Vegas
was like nope and that's why that
happened but yeah I am NOT going to be
too sad to see these buildings disappear
I have saved them just to be certain but
I just didn't feel like having these
buildings in here they kind of block the
view from the other buildings and I kind
of had loads of buildings that we're
just about as high as each other and it
didn't really fit so I feel like it
would probably be a better idea to
remove all of them and replace them with
apartment buildings and that's why I
decided to remove this building as well
because I also felt like this building
didn't fit so this is pretty much the
great remove everything episode and
at this point I realized that I actually
put the videos in wrong order isn't that
beautiful at this point I'm still
recoloring that building oh that that is
actually great that's pretty bad
actually though to be fair to pretty bad
color scheme that I went for that's kind
of a problem that i have with the city
the color schemes with many sets you
don't really get the washed-out colors
that i want to have on skyscrapers so i
just decided to go with grays and whites
and blacks everywhere but that just
means that everything is gray and white
black and there's of course the winners
are blue but other than that there's not
really much change in the colors so i
might want to do something about that
now i don't quite know what to do with
that I don't really know what kind of
colors to add and I guess I'll just kind
of experiment with that and see if I can
actually make some skyscrapers with
brick walls and stuff like that I don't
really know I have no clear whether what
the future is going to hold for me
because of course I'm just building
random things now this is this building
is going to be the replacement for that
older building which I decided to remove
because it looks well for one it looked
too similar to the building that I have
at the entrance of well it's not really
an entrance to the city you don't really
have an entrance to a city but I just
felt like it was too similar to that
building that was already there and it
also didn't really feel like a building
that I'd have in a city and especially
not at this place so I decided to go
with a more well classical kind of
building and a general this just seems
more realistic and of course I also kind
of want to have a park over here and
many people have been talking about this
although not that many people many
people have been talking about amusement
park but i'm not going to add that
simply because this is a city and i
would like to focus on the city itself
and actually move away from the usual
amusement park business that roller
coaster can three players I usually have
and that's why I decided to add a normal
park over here just a normal kind of
square shaped park like Central Park in
Manhattan of course isn't Manhattan but
I still wanted to have something like
that and that brings me to one of the
other reasons also why I removed this
building but also the highest skyscraper
because it was kind of blocking the view
from where I want to place my Park in
the future to all of the towers behind
it so
mayn't I were that really high one with
a glass spire and the other ones so I
decided to remove all of this and that's
basically the story behind that also
this building that I'm currently working
on is going to be a pizzeria kind of
thing I don't really know why I'm doing
that I just felt like I want to play
something like that I kind of need to
have some more restaurants and stuff
like that going on in the city and
speaking of things that I need in the
city I've got a small list based on
requests and things that people have
said in the comments section I still
want to perhaps give a cinema a shot
that I'm not entirely sure about that I
want to see if I can build a city hall
somewhere and I kind of want to base all
of the well sort of important buildings
such as the city hall around the park
that I went to build in the middle and
so that I have a generally nice area
with all their well nice buildings
around it and that's gonna be um nice
yeah such as my vocabulary and this this
building is pretty simple but it's using
a set that I rarely ever use then I
decided to just give a shot and see what
i could do with it and it's a pretty
limited set but it did work and it came
in very handy so that's awesome the only
thing that I kind of had issues with is
well not really issues but I kind of
felt like I don't really know what to do
with this it's the roof because well
that's also partly due to fact that I am
somewhat inexperienced with roofs like
this and I don't always know what what
to do so I just decided to go with a TNS
roof tile set and just throw that
Spanish groove on there just it's an
Italian building but let's just throw
Spanish roofs on it because it's
mediterranean might as well it's in the
same it's that same idea whenever you're
building Japanese buildings like I don't
really have the right sets lectures
let's just use this Chinese set because
it's all the same anyway and the only
people were actually going to complain
are going to be the people from those
countries but the percentage of
subscribers that I have there are from
Spain is so low that I'm not going to
care about them no
I care about all of my subscribers I am
I love you are so and this building that
this building was very annoying I'm
going to kill this building or not this
building but these windows at least
because I place these windows and I was
like yes good these windows are amazing
and I was like oh my god love and I
wanted to kiss the building but I
couldn't because it's in Monaco circuit
3 but then I kind of zoomed out and I
saw the windows disappearing I was like
yeah and that just meant that i just
lost the buildings as soon as i would
seem out the render distance is just
honestly it's quite terrible and that's
quite unfortunate because that means
that i can't really use those windows so
i had to remove them after a while I'm
pretty sure I did that no I didn't even
do that I just decided to keep them and
that means that I'm gonna be very
careful with filming things because I
won't be able to well look at this
building from a far distance so that's
gonna suck so what do I do with that I
don't really know i might play some
trees in front of it so you can't see it
and be like haha now you can you cannot
see it because you you're not allowed to
see because the windows and all that
speaking of windows the windows of that
italian set that i use for the pizza rio
kind of meh I mean they're see-through
and it's not really something that I
like in windows because of course it
does mean that the window is more
realistic but it also means that I kind
of have to do either interiors or leave
the interiors blank and have a weird
interior looking window kind of thing
and that's not something that I really
want so on to this piece where I built
the new apartment buildings right on the
spot where I removed the old building so
i guess it's rip old building I don't
even think I really had a name for that
building it was kind of a weird building
however it was an apartment building
though so I'm gonna replace it with
something just quite the same only this
apartment buildings actually gonna have
balconies and that is something that I
kind of wanted to talk about because I
realized at some point hey all of my
buildings they don't have any balconies
which is quite weird I like it's it's
like I don't want my citizens to sit
side and of course i do want them to sit
sit outside this is a silver city
beautiful view excellent architecture
and amazing nature of course it's all
built by me so of course I want them to
see that so I need to add balconies
everywhere so my people can enjoy my
beautiful city so that's why I decided
to build a building that actually has
balconies that's not actually the reason
the reason is just because apartment
buildings have balconies you don't often
come across apartment buildings that
don't have them so it's all it also
gives them a very distinctive look that
I kind of didn't take in mind when I
first built this tower and it doesn't
really matter for the other towers
because I like that designs and the
commercial buildings so they don't
really need balconies unless you want
your yo you're like whatever I'm please
to sit outside but you don't want that
because that means I'm not working so
that doesn't really matter however my
apartment building should have balconies
so that was a mistake on my part and
that's why I'm building this building
and for this building because this is
actually an apartment building and by
the way don't know don't worry about
those floors I removed them but
basically for this building because this
is an apartment building and it's quite
big or at least is high I actually did
use those same windows again and then
when I zoomed out I was like yeah I
really can't do this you can't just put
trees in front of this and be like yeah
you're not going to see the building
anymore because this building is high so
yeah that was quite a problem so
eventually i just had to decide to
remove all of the windows because render
distance problem and replace them with
the windows that i've already overused
so we're back to square one which is a
square that i would not like to be at
but it yeah i was kind of forced into
doing it i would rather have the same
window all over the place than having
windows that look good but with terrible
reminiscences so that's the story behind
this also yeah this is me replacing all
of the windows I'm gonna say something
well before I actually do it I don't
know why I would do that but I've got
some time to spare this this tower is
actually going to be a twin tower is
sort of thing and that's just I'll just
throw that out there I just felt like
adding some extra dense
to you to the city so I decided to clean
this tower and I might actually add a
small Park to it but I don't really know
because it's already next to the park
it's just that I don't know what to do
with the space that's next to this tower
over here I don't really yeah I can't
decide where I want the residential or
commercial buildings so that's kind of
the pickled am in right now oh and then
I had to I had to make the top of the
building and this was a total disaster I
think I've spent longer on the unlike
it's not even aspire it's just an
elevator thingy and then hvac but I
think I've spent longer on bats then on
the actual building itself nearly and
that was quite stupid but I just
couldn't settle on the design then I had
in mind for it it's like the easiest
part on the building and the part that
nobody pays attention to is the pipe
that I spent longest on and I get stuck
at isn't that beautiful that's nice
welcome to my life by the way so that's
why this is going to take yeah quite a
while because right now I feel like I
felt like it was too high and too boring
so I decided to add this little concrete
wall with all those nice little patterns
and very nice but of course it was still
too high and it was still probably too
boring as well and those scholars might
actually be a bit too over-the-top or
weird so yeah that doesn't really make
too much sense either so let's get rid
of that that's basically what i thought
at that point and let's get rid of the
glass as well because glass makes no
sense on top of a building like i don't
know what the idea behind that was but I
was like hey that's a glass on top of
this building so I did it but that just
didn't work because it's a kind of an
elevator thing and I don't even know
what you know what you could actually
call those things okay I just like to
build buildings I don't actually know
too much about them it's even when I'm
building buildings in roller coaster
good three it's still the same story as
with roller coasters I build roller
coasters but I don't even know that much
about them I'm not erotic oh so loose
yes I just happen to be in this entire
community so um hi guys so yeah there we
go there now Twin Towers and I think
they look pretty decent I'm not too keen
on the textures but that's not really
something that I can really do something
about of course i can replace them with
other walls but there aren't other walls
that are this um well yeah flexible
though there might be but i don't have
them so yeah that is that and i'm going
to add a small connection between the
two buildings just to get that little
well part of the building there and just
to kind of fill up the space and connect
the two buildings of course because
that's cool and of course trees because
we need some grass and trees and nice
paths and all that its pretty important
actually when it comes to skyscrapers to
not only make your skyscrapers
themselves nice but also make the
surroundings nice it's pretty important
thing but yeah that's basically it's for
today these are nice little buildings i
finished at this point and we've removed
loads of things so it's time to move
forward and onward to the next episode
bye